we are learning one of the two people
reported missing after a massive fire at
a construction site in Charlotte North
Carolina is dead the other is still
unaccounted for the huge Flames engulfed
the structure which then partially
collapsed 15 people were rescued Nicole
scanga has the latest from the scene
nearly a hundred firefighters rushed in
to help oh there goes
after a massive five-alarm fire ripped
through an apartment building under
construction in Charlotte Thursday
morning it was a very fast moving fire
high heat conditions well over 2000
degrees the city's fire chief said the
intense Blaze trapped firefighters on
two separate occasions but others were
able to rescue them in all firefighters
rescued 15 workers from the construction
site we still have a crane operator in
the crane including one who was trapped
on a crane for more than an hour hoisted
hundreds of feet above the Raging Fire
that crane operator was
transported by medic
with non-life-threatening injuries Crews
also had to work quickly to put out
Flames that spread to nearby buildings
we had a number of rooftop fires due to
the The Embers that were just traveling
all over the place due to the volume and
size of the fire they started getting
bigger and bigger and bigger until the
fire department got here Glenn Freeman
is a truck driver who was delivering
windows to the building that went up in
Flames it was just black smoke rolling
and I heard some of the construction
workers say that they thought of one of
the machines that caught on fire we're
going to be on scene for a period of
time we have a number of investigators
here that will determine the cause
and last night firefighters began moving
heavy machinery in to start clearing
some of the debris from this site
overnight rescue operations temporarily
put on pause after Engineers deemed this
building no longer structurally sound
now concerns it could collapse at any
moment Nate
Nicole thank you